THE 3-2 O.T. LOS
KEPT IN BY
HE WILL CALL THAT HIMSELF. GAME.
MICK, WHAT ARE YOUOU IN LINE BY
KEVIN KONECNY. WING.
HE PULLS UP AND TRIES TO GET IT
BACK TO BERTUZZI. MOVEMENT OF R.
THAT IS THE EVERY FACET.
>> Mickey: THEY CONTINUE TO INT.
GET ON THE PRIORITY WAIT LIST
FOR NEXT SEASON BY PLACINGG JUN.
I ON THE PHILLYSCOSKAR LINDBLOMO
HIGH OVER THE ONE OFF
INTO THE CORNER.
>> Mickey: THEY ALREADY QUIT.
A MOMENT AGO, FLYERS
BATTLING WITH PLAY TO
CONNAUTON.
IT'S LARKIN THAT COMES AWAY WITH
THE PUCK.
THROUGH THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
ININ COME VERY
CLOSE. ZONE.
SECOND ATTEMPT DOE
>> Referee: PENALTY.
>> Mickey: WHAT A GLORIOUS ALON.
I DON'T THINK IT HIT THE GAME.
HART.S GREISS CLEANS HIS
NOTHING KICK SAVE BY HART.
>> Mickey: OH, HISTORY MONTH.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS THAT. LOY
WILL PICK UP THE THE THIRD.
GREISS HAS
>> THE RED WINGS HAVE A MUCH
MORE
LAUGHTON TO ATKINSON. TO LARKIN.
THE REST IS